it's a kind of what you might call a
visual code recognition technology image
that sounds a bit posh doesn't it
but it really means you point a camera
at some image and the computer
recognizes something about the image and
it can trigger some information and if
that still doesn't make sense then you
actually will be really familiar with
these things because they've been around
since the 1950s here is the barcode
which you'll find on all sorts of
products in the supermarket at home turn
over anything as a barcode and this
encodes information a series of numbers
in this case into thinner or thicker
lines pointer camera or camera like
device at it and it triggers some
information here's another kind of code
that you're probably familiar with which
is the QR code which is an evolution of
the barcode to encode things like whole
web addresses uniquely so you can go
from some kind of poster on a wall to
actually kind of visit a website by
pointing your phone at it they've got a
really interesting property and when you
look at them visually you're pretty
aware what they are you can see
immediately that's a barcode and you can
see immediately that's a QR code and
that's kind of good you know what it is
and you know where to point your camera
and you know what you're looking for and
that makes things good but in other
circumstances it's not so good because
they are well how can I put it there big
ugly really aren't they let's be clear
so there have been various attempt by
companies to kind of improve the visual
appeal and you can actually see them a
bit here there are some really clever
designers who are taking things like
barcodes and adding extra bits of logo
to at least kind of prettify them or or
do various other bits if you did that
really cleverly you might want to use
one on your product a bit more visibly
but there's no getting away from it that
at the end of the day unless you want
the world around you plastered with
barcodes and QR codes the aesthetic of
these limits some of the situations in
which you'd want to use them so we were
kind of interested in how could we
create visual markers like these but but
that had a kind of nicer aesthetic and
also how could we give you creative
control over actually making that
aesthetic in the first place and we
picked on a piece of work that was done
by a guy called Enrico Costanza while he
was at ETH in Zurich and he came up with
this idea of using the top holo
of the image as the waving coding
information so what does that mean that
means that I need to draw a certain
number of regions that contain a certain
number of blobs within them and if I get
that number right then the shape of them
doesn't actually matter so let me have a
go this could be interesting I'm afraid
I'm not a great visual artist as you're
about to see so this is me drawing sort
of my drawing here I'm drawing
topologically five regions that are all
connected together there you can see
them and I'm now going to put some solid
and the rule of the game is of these
things have to be solid
that one's a dot and that one's a line
ones across another couple of dots
because I'm so boring I can't think of
anything else to put so I've now created
a pretty simple topological shape
it consists of five regions each region
contains a certain number of dots and in
this case there is one one one one two
it could be the code to maybe let's have
a go I now have my aesthetic codes app
running on my mobile phone here so I'm
going to just have a bit of a scan of
this and lo and behold that a red marker
says it's found what it is and it's now
eventually going to kind of take me to
what whatever I wanted to go to in this
case I programmed it to go to a website
which happens to advertise aesthetic
codes of course but you know that you
could program it to point to pretty much
anything you want because it's it's only
concerned with the number of regions and
the number of things within those
regions the key thing to remember is
that the shape doesn't matter so let me
have a another pop at this so that looks
suspiciously like it's the same code oh
there we go we've got it again and it's
going to take to the same website the
order in which these appear it doesn't
matter at all yet it's just the number
of regions the number of sub bits they
contain the thing that we did if you
like to move this on was that we got it
out of the hands of computer scientists
like myself who don't draw particularly
well into the hands of people who's you
know whose skill it is to draw beautiful
patterns so we took it to designers and
we started to teach them how to use it
to see what they would come up with and
that's where things got really
interesting so
we work with some folks at Central
Martins College and the ceramic design
department and gave them some training
and we said come back to us with some
patterns and here's what they created we
gave each designer three codes so that's
code one that's code 2 and that's code 3
embedded within a pattern what's
happening here is that the code is
actually appearing several times within
this pattern and that makes it more
robust in computer science terms that's
redundancy built in and we'll come to
why that's really important in just a
moment so this is the same designer
who's created three different patterns
with the coding so this is the same
information and this is what's so
beautiful about this technique you can
kind of create these different designs
that embody the same information or very
similar looking designs can embody
different information and it's all down
to the skill of the designer and how
clever they are are hiding these codes
within the images as to which of those
effects they might want to create so it
becomes really playful and creative kind
of way of thinking about design and you
know we can flip through a few more than
some lovely designs here exceed such as
Annabel Dee's designs she's gone for a
range of styles from the kind of literal
to the abstract and so on the penguins
which approved they're from Nicole
extremely popular so we have this kind
of pattern book of designs
I guess the interesting question you
might all know kind of what is it for I
suppose why would you want to do this
and what we're interested in is opening
up a conversation about how we might
decorate the world around us with
interesting interactive surfaces what
you might start to do with those and
this is an exploratory process so to
kick it off we were fortunate enough to
work with a restaurant chain called boo
Sabha based in London and there are kind
of Thai restaurant they take a great
deal of time to kind of if you like
source their recipes and do kind of
field research and they kind of put them
together really carefully so there's a
lot of background and history to the
recipes and they also tend to kind of
serve them in almost individual dishes
so we worked with Basava to start to
create create a series of restaurant
objects that might tell you stories so
we put some of the patterns you've just
seen onto plates this brings us back to
the
earlier mention are made of redundancy
so one of the reasons we wanted
redundancy in the patterns is because if
you take a close look at this plate
you'll notice there's lots of specular
reflections on that are happening here
and these specular reflections are
highly visible to the camera when you
pointed at that so these will actually
blot out wherever they happen so they're
actually going to blot out the pattern
so in order to avoid this kind of things
you really need to decorate the object
with multiple versions of the code and
of course plates get dirty or fabrics
get covered or marked or scuffed or
whatever so redundancy which of course
is a well-known concept in computer
science comes back in another another
way here so besar burr worked with us
and we kind of imagined a number of uses
for these we had plates that for example
would give you the particular recipe
that went with them so you point your
phone at the plate maybe you didn't take
the plate home as a souvenir or buy it
and then in your kitchen you can get the
latest Basava recipe placemats so when
you go into the restaurant you get your
placemat setting and this might give you
information about your particular order
so where where was it in the process at
one point weeding you know played with
the idea of a video view into the
kitchen to see your actual food being
kind of cooked a sort of menu and this
might give you the dish of the day if
you looked at that because that
dynamically changes every day so the
idea is you'd have the standard menu
items inside pointing at the aesthetic
code would kind of give you the current
dish of the day
and you know this is kind of very open
conversation so we're kind of currently
thinking about yeah other future
applications of this I think one of the
most exciting things for me is to scale
it up to much bigger surfaces so what
I'm really interested in things like
interactive wallpapers interactive kind
of furniture patterns possibly clothing
where you've got multiple codes in a big
area perhaps different codes that as you
look at it in different ways kind of
tell you a story or or make it kind of
more interactive I mean one of the big
open questions at the moment is one
about human-computer interaction is that
how would people interact with these
things
because you know as we said earlier the
great thing about these codes is you can
see where they are and you know where to
point your phone the more you hide the
codes within why the patterns the harder
it becomes the end user to actually know
how they're meant to interact so that's
a kind of key problem to solve yeah
whether a surface is interactive yeah
just trying to figure out that well is
that its standard texture or is that
something I can interact with so there's
quite a big interaction design challenge
there I think there are various ways
around it and I mean a simple one is you
can just put more or less cues on the
phone you can put you can put the
outline shape of the Penguins on the app
and that says you're looking for these
and wherever you see things like
penguins or whatever then that might be
an interactive code or perhaps you can
more subtly kind of communicate it in
the design itself but in a way that
doesn't destroy the aesthetic with any
technique there are some kind of
limitations as well so at the moment
we're fairly limited to the size of the
code space although in theory you could
have an arbitrary number of regions and
lots and lots of blobs within those
regions it soon gets quite unreliable
for a standard mobile phone camera to be
able to kind of tell exactly where the
lines join up so in practice we're
probably working at the moment with a
code space of just a few hundred codes
that you could distinguish perhaps even
at best although you know the research
is looking to push that further and
further but you really have to contrast
it with things like the barcode and the
QR code which you know for there if you
like simplicity of design are really
well engineered to be scalable and
robust so I guess as with so many things
you know in computer science
there's a kind of series of trade-offs
that place not to say well this is the
right way for the whole world to be and
this is the wrong way QR codes and
barcodes are scalable robust you know
what they are the minute you see them
you know when and how to interact these
aesthetic codes as we call them are
creative and funky you can make them
yourself they can be beautiful but they
pose a bunch of questions about how do
you know where they are and at the
moment we're challenged with how do you
make them scalable and you know
what happens when different codes map to
the same information rather than a
unique thing so important that's always
to see it is a kind of a design space of
trade-offs more than is one thing being
right and the other wrong we released
the app if you like is something that
you can test out and play with for
yourself so just as I did once you kind
of read through the website you may work
out what the rules are and at that point
you can start to kind of create your own
designs and test them out when we came
to him anyone who has a go at that the
order in which the kind of the regions
if you like are found that doesn't
matter but if you have different codes
within a bigger pattern that might
matter the order in which you are
expected to search them out